All right, we're on
problem number 8.
And they ask us which equation
is equivalent to 5x minus 2
times 7x plus 1 is
equal to 14x?
So I'm guessing they just want
to simplify this a little bit
and see if we get to one
of these choices.
So let's do that.
So we start with 5x minus
2 times 7x plus
1 is equal to 14x.
This is I think the most obvious
thing to simplify.
This 2 times the 7x plus 1, or
we can even say minus 2 times
7x plus 1, so then this becomes
5x plus-- I'm just
going to distribute the minus
2 times all of this.
Plus minus 2 times
17x is minus 14x.
And then minus 2 times 1 is
minus 2 is equal to 14x.
And let's see, on all of these
choices they have 14x on the
right-hand side.
So they just want us
to simplify this.
So this simplifies to 5x, plus
minus 14, so that's minus 14x
minus 2 is equal to 14x.
So we have 5x minus 14x.
So what's 5 minus 14?
It's what?
Minus 9, right?
Minus 9x minus 2 is
equal to 14x.
That is choice A.
Now, one thing that maybe
I realized, I kind
of skipped a step.
Let me just do this, just so
that you understand this step
that I did here.
We could have just said minus
and then distribute the 2.
So we could have right there
said 5x minus positive 2 times
7x, 14x, plus 2 times
1, plus 2.
I'm just doing the
left-hand side.
And then we could have
distributed the minus sign.
So you get 5x minus
14x minus 2.
Either way, it would have gotten
us to this point and
then we could have simplified
here and gotten choice A.
Next problem.
Which equation is equivalent
to-- OK, so another case where
I'm guessing they just want us
to simplify these equations.
So let me write that down.
4 times 2 minus 5x is equal to
6 minus 3 times 1 minus 3x.
All right, let's distribute
this 4 first. So you get 4
times 2 is 8.
4 times minus 5x is minus 20x.
Minus 20x is equal to 6 minus--
maybe you might have
been tempted to say, oh, 6 minus
3, that's 3, and then
distribute it.
Remember, order of operations.
Multiplication comes first. So
we have to multiply the 3
times the 1 minus 3x before
we can deal with the 6.
Well, on the other side there
was just the multiplication
first. All right.
So here, 3 times 1 minus
3x, so it'll be 3.
I'm just going to do
minus a positive 3
times each of these.
So 3 times a negative
3 is minus 9x.
And now I can distribute
this minus sign.
So let's see, on the left-hand
side I have-- let me do it in
a brighter color.
The left-hand side I have 8
minus 20x is equal to 6, and
then I'm going to subtract
this whole thing.
So you can view it as
distributing a negative 1
times both of these.
So 6 plus minus 3, or just 6
minus 3, and then a minus
times a minus plus 9x.
All right.
Now let's see what we could
do to help simplify this.
What happens if we add
20x to both sides?
Then on the left-hand side, it
goes away, so we're just left
with 8 is equal to-- well,
let me just do that.
6 minus 3.
I added 20x, so plus 29x.
I really should have simplified
this 6 minus 3, but
I didn't want to do too
much in one step.
So 8 is equal to 3 plus 29x, and
then if we subtract 3 from
both sides here, we get
8 minus 3 is 5.
That 3 goes away and you get
29x, and that is choice C.
29x is equal to 5.
Next question, problem
number 10.
And I should be careful that
you don't think that all of
this stuff is for
this problem.
The total cost, c, in dollars
of renting a sailboat for n
days is given by
this equation.
If the total cost was $360,
for how many days was the
sailboat rented?
So they're giving
us c. c is $360.
So they're telling us that $360,
that's the total cost,
and that's going to be equal to
120 plus 60 times with the
total days rented, times 60n.
And that's what they want
us to figure out, n.
How many days was the
sailboat rented?
Let's see, so if you should
subtract 120 from both sides
of this equation, you get
240 is equal to 60n.
I'll go here.
And if you divide both sides of
this by 60, 240 divided by
60, that's the same thing as 24
divided by 6, so that's 4.
And then 60n divided by 60 is,
of course, 1, so that is n.
So the sailboat was
rented for 4 days.
All right, problem number 11.
And I cut and pasted part of
it, but they want us to
determine, what was the first
incorrect step that they did
in this problem?
So let's see if we can
determine that.
So let's see.
Solve 3 times x plus 5 is
equal to 2x plus 35.
Fair enough.
So in this first step they
distributed 3 times
x and 3 times 5.
Right, 3x plus 15 is equal to
2x plus 35, so step 1 looks
good to me.
Let me do that in
a darker color.
Step 1 looks good.
They distributed the 3.
Now let's see what they
did in step 2.
Let's see, if I wanted to solve
this, I would subtract
2x from both sides, and it looks
like that's what they
attempted to do because they
got rid of this 2x, right?
On the right-hand side, they
went from 2x plus 35 to just
35, so somehow they got rid of
this 2x, and the only way to
get rid of it is to subtract
2x from both sides.
Now, if I subtract 2x from both
sides, sure enough, the
right-hand side will just
be left with the 35.
The left-hand side will have
the 15, of course.
And then I have minus
2x plus 3x.
Well, minus 2x plus
3x, that's x.
So this 5x, that shouldn't
be there.
It should be x plus
15 is equal to 35.
So even though they were trying
to get rid of this 2x
and they should have subtracted
2x from both sides,
they inadvertently added 2x
here, so they said 2x plus 3x
is equal to 5x.
Well, that was wrong.
You have to subtract.
And you're just left with x
plus 15 is equal to 35.
So step 2 is when they made
their first error.
Problem 120.
A 120-foot-long rope is
cut into 3 pieces.
The first piece of the
rope-- let me draw.
This is begging for a diagram.
All right, so they say the first
piece of rope is twice
as long as the second
piece of rope.
And then they say the third
piece of rope is three times
as long as the second
piece of rope.
Everything is a multiple of
the second piece of rope.
So the second one was the
shortest one, just reading it.
The first is twice as
long as the second.
The third is three
times as long.
So if I just drew it.
So if this is the second
length of rope,
let's call that x.
That's the second
length of rope.
And they told us the first piece
of rope is twice as long
as the second piece of rope.
OK, so if this is the first
piece of rope right here, it's
going to be twice as long as
the second piece of rope.
So that's 2x.
Fair enough.
And then they tell us-- I'll
do this in magenta.
The third piece of rope is three
times as long as the
second piece of rope.
So this is the third
piece of rope here.
It's three times as long as
the second piece of rope.
So it's 3x.
And they say, what is
the length of the
longest piece of rope?
All right, so let's
think about it.
If I add up all of these
segments, what
do they add up to?
Well, they tell us that it's
120-foot-long rope.
So let me add that up.
So if I do 2x plus x plus
3x, that's going
to equal 120 feet.
That is equal to 120 feet.
That whole distance is 120.
So 2x plus x is 3x plus 3x, you
get 6x is equal to 120.
You divide both sides by 6, You
get x is-- let's see, 120
divided by 6 is 20.
All right, that's what x is.
That's the second piece of rope
or the shortest piece of
rope because they
tell us that.
The other ones are some multiple
of that length.
But they want to know, what is
the length of the longest
piece of rope?
Well, the longest piece of
rope is clearly piece 3.
It's three times the
second piece.
Piece 1 was only two times.
So this is what they
want to know.
They want to know what
3x is equal to.
So 3x is equal to three times
20, which is equal to 60 feet.
And that's choice C.
Next problem.
Let's see if I have time.
Yeah, I think I have time.
I might as well attempt
to fit it in.
All right.
Don't want to rush
them, though.
Let's see.
The cost to rent a construction
crane is $750 per
day plus $250 per hour of use.
What is the maximum number of
hours the crane can be used
each day if the rental cost is
not to exceed $2,500 per day?
OK, so how much is
the cost per day?
So the cost per day
is equal to $750.
So no matter how little or much
we use it, we have to pay
that $750 per day.
So it's equal to $750 plus $250
per hour, so plus $250
times the number of hours.
This is what our total
cost is per day.
And they want to say, what is
the maximum number of hours
the crane can be used each day
if the rental cost is not to
exceed $2,500 per day?
So this whole thing has to be
less than or equal to $2,500.
The total cost has to be less
than or equal to $2,500.
So now let's just solve this
equation right there.
And I'll do it up here.
So we know that $750 plus
$250-- let me do
it down here actually.
More space.
So what's the first thing
we could do here?
We could subtract 750 from both
sides of this equation.
So we get 250 times h is less
than or equal to-- 2,500 minus
750, that's what?
1,750?
Yeah, because 1,500
minus 750 is 750.
1,750.
I just subtracted 750 from both
sides of this equation.
Let me write that down.
So I said minus 750 plus that.
And then I said minus 750.
And, of course, minus 750 plus
750, that goes to 0.
That's why you don't see
anything over here.
And on the right-hand side,
2,500 minus 750 is 1,750.
All right, now let's just divide
both sides by 250.
We don't have to do anything to
the inequality sign since
250 is a positive number.
So the hours, the maximum number
of hours, the hours
have to be less than or equal to
1,750/250, which is-- let's
see, 1,750 divided by 250.
That's the same thing as
175 divided by 25.
25 goes into 175,
what is that?
I want to say seven times?
7 times 5 is 35.
7 times 2 is 14 plus 3 is 17.
Right.
So h has to be less than
or equal to 7 hours.
And that is choice C.
See you in the next video.